[Musique]
vous souvenez vous de votre école
maternelle vous souvenez vous des
activités que la maîtresse vous faisait
faire moi j'ai un souvenir très marquant
la maîtresse nous avait demandé
d'apporter des morceaux de file des
brins de laine des bouts de ficelle ça
faisait comme ça et avec tous ces
morceaux on avait tissé des petits
carrés de toiles multicolores on en est
très très fiers et aujourd'hui je vais
vous raconter la suite de cette histoire
la suite de cette histoire c'est la
méthode de tissage des ruptures urbaine
à une époque j'étais en charge de
l'autoroute a10 qui relie paris à
bordeaux et qui traverse tours il ya le
maire qui m'appellent et me convoque
dans son bureau
monsieur rousseau cette autoroute et ne
coupure insupportable dans la ville l
acer l'agglomération il va falloir faire
quelque chose
les élections municipales c'est dans un
an
alors ça coûtera ce que ça coûtera mais
c'est vous qui allez payer ou doux faut
faire quelque chose mais quoi faire mais
pourquoi l'autoroute est là en 1850 et
un canal qui a été construit entre la
loire et le cher en 1900 ce canal a été
abandonné avec l'arrivée des voies
ferrées en 1945 tour a été bombardé et
les gravats ont été jetés dans le canal
qui a été comblé au début des années 60
quand on cherchait à construire la
déviation de tours s'étaient pas encore
l'autoroute suivre la déviation de tours
tout naturellement il y avait un
emplacement disponible
la déviation s'est installé à la place
du canal voilà pour l'histoire
mais que faire alors en circulant dans
tour en recherche d'idées jette en
voiture j'ai eu une révélation mais
vraiment le moment en regardant mon gps
c'est la photo de mon gps cette photo
c'est très exactement la carte mentale
des élus tourangeau la coupure
insupportable la blessure saignante
c'est le trait rouge ces lotos les
routes urbaines même à deux fois deux
voies
c'est les routes blanches mais les
petits pointillés c'est quoi les petits
pointillés là c est mis sur cette carte
c'est des voies ferrées j'ai mis en bleu
est-ce que les voies ferrées coupe
laville
eh bien non non parce que le train c'est
moderne et sympathique l'autoroute ça
pue ça fait du bruit c'est la bagnole ce
n'est pas moderne c'est la dimension
symbolique des infrastructures alors
arrêtons nous sur un concept c'est
jacques lacan le monde est réel
symbolique est imaginaire il est tout à
la fois réelle symbolique et imaginaire
vous pouvez pas séparer tout ça c'est
simultanées ça veut dire que notre champ
d'action s'est autant symbolique que le
réel mais qu'on agit soit symbolique on
agit sur le réel
alors avec jérôme barratier directeur
l'agent d'urbanistes et abdu gnaba un
anthropologue
nous avons été voir les habitants et
nous avons été des interrogés quel était
leur perception
quel était leur vécu et les habitants et
10 trois choses la première
l'autoroute est une frontière naturelle
acceptée par tous c'est une frontière
mais des naturel la seconde la valeur
d'usagé colossal
je m'en sers tous les jours pour aller
au boulot pour emmener mes enfants pour
faire mes courses surtout n'y touchez
pas l'autoroute c'est fragile vous pas y
toucher et la troisième si vous pouvez
pas déplacer l'autoroute en dehors de la
ville
déplacez bordeaux sous-entendu ainsi les
à parisien ils arrêteront de passer chez
nous quoi ça c'est ce que disent des
habitants
alors j'ai fait une carte et ça c'est
une carte rousseau pourquoi rousseau
c'est mon nom mais surtout c'est mon
regard
j'ai mis en noir la loire le cher en
orange les voies ferrées et le trait
bleu là c'est l'autoroute
quelle est la lecture de cette carte la
lecture de cette carte c'est un
territoire morcelé par la loire le
cheikh des voies ferrées et le fils de
vie qui tient ensemble territoire le
fils de vie qui tient ensemble la vie
des habitants
c'est l'autoroute voilà un regard un peu
différent de celui que les élus mmes
présenté au début mais alors que faire
avec ce tissu de cette exploration
on a proposé des actions
la première est extrêmement difficile
c'est un projet 10 euros et se mobiliser
sur un projet à 10 euros ça demande des
moyens solides
vous voyez d'un côté à pied de vigne
vierge très bien bossé l'autre côté un
mur en béton a cédé le projet c'est quoi
ça allait acheter un pied de vigne
vierge c'est moins de 10 euros est à la
base du mur on plante le pied de vigne
vierge mais simplement planté des pieds
de vigne vierge n'a aucune espèce
d'intérêt
on va les frapper aux portes des
habitants on va trouver quelqu'un qui a
envie d'arroser les pieds de vigne
vierge
on va aller voir l'association des
jardiniers qui au pied va mettre un
potager urbain et puis on va faire une
fête pour lancement du potager on va le
mettre dans le journal local
et là il ya quelque chose qui va
commencer à se passer et du lien humain
début d'une histoire
voilà un exemple d'action une deuxième
ça se passait il ya quelques semaines
c'est un spectacle s'appelle le wild
west show librement transposer de roméo
juliette de shakespeare et ça se passait
sous l'autoroute il ya 3000 spectateurs
3000 habitants qui sont venus pour aller
voir un spectacle sous l'autoroute et là
on transforme l'autoroute d'un endroit
où on passe d'un endroit qui sépare en
un lieu un endroit où on va pour aller
voir un spectacle pour faire un fait on
recrée un emplacement une troisième
action c'est un concours d'urbanisme et
à l'issue de ce concours l'équipe
gagnante qui s'appelle micro pour os a
inventé un concept de mini place urbaine
y en a 13 qui sont interconnectés et qui
sont implantées dans des lieux
totalement improbable des endroits on
s'arrêterait jamais et ses mini place
c'est des endroits on va pouvoir aller
simplement s'asseoir converser et encore
une fois ça revient des petits lieux de
vie qui s'implantent sont des endroits
choisis
on pourrait imaginer mettre les bus
urbains sur l'autoroute pour que
l'autoroute devienne un morceau de ville
de cette expérience et d'autre j'ai tiré
une méthode que j'ai appelé la méthode
de tissage des ruptures urbaine comment
ça se passe la première étape on
assemble une équipe on assemble une
équipe on prend des ingénieurs
scientifiques sciences humaines
anthropologues sociologues entre les
deux architectes urbanistes
environnementalistes et cette équipe
elle valait explorer un territoire le
dessus le dessous son histoire ses
cicatrices ses réseaux et de là elle va
pas les rédiger des rapports de là elle
va à les assembler les histoires
individuelles dans un récit collectif
qui va nourrir un rêve à partager et ça
ils le font entrer tout ce qu'ils ont vu
il retourne sur le terrain et là sur le
terrain ils vont chercher tout ce qui
relève de la frontière tout ce qui
relève de la rupture tout ce qui relève
de la séparation et ça il va incorporer
ça dans le récit et retourne encore une
fois et la recherche
les lignes d'uzège tous qui assemble par
exemple il peut y avoir deux
organisations totalement opposées mal
intérieur d organiser
lyon deux personnes qu'ils s'entendent
parfaitement parce que je joue au foot
le dimanche faut savoir identifier genre
de choses et là le point majeur c'est
qu'au croisement des lignes de rupture
et des lignes d'usagé ils vont implanter
un plan de micro actions cohérentes
entre elles et ses actions et les
implants pour croisement qui sont des
points névralgiques
certains parlent d'acupuncture urbaine
et 7 acupuncture urbaine à ceux faits
par ces micro action et encore une fois
ce plan d'action on va écrire mais
l'essentiel c'est pas l'écrire
l'essentiel c'est de le raconter le
raconter aux habitants le raconter aux
autres partenaires est comme ça il va se
propager ensuite on renouvelle on
renouvelle c'est la méthode de tissage
des ruptures urbaine alors cette méthode
qu'en faire qu'en faire imaginer de
l'appliquer dans des quartiers
populaires
imaginez de l'appliquer dans une
campagne isolée imaginer surtout de
l'appliquer dans votre propre quartier
il n'est pas nécessaire d'être
professionnel il suffit d'être plusieurs
est tour à tour on va prendre incarner
le rôle de l'anthropologue du sociologue
de l'ingénieur je vous invite à
expérimenter rassembler les brins de
laine des morceaux de toiles
multicolores aletti cd rupture urbaine
et soulevé un élan humaniste et
enthousiaste merci
[Applaudissements]